This program is being presented to you
by the Heraeus International Winter
School on gravity and light.
So, good morning and welcome everybody
to the central lecture of the Heraeus
International Winter School on gravity
and light. This is the winter school
we have here in Linz this year.
And the
topic of this winter school is the
structure of space and time and more
precisely from a physical point of view,
the structure of gravity theory, which
if it's relativistic is general
relativity
and the theory of relativistic matter.
So, you probably already met matter
and gravity as well. Now, these are the
relativistic versions of those and the
famous Einstein equations that now
celebrate their 100th birthday this
year.
These Einstein equations connect the
matter contents of the universe
with the gravity in the universe. Of
course, matter gravitates.
But, what is new in general relativity
is that matter, the gravitational effect
of matter is actually encoded in a
change of the structure of space-time
itself, namely in the curvature of
space-time.
So, one side of the Einstein equations
talks about matter, the other side of
the Einstein equations talks about
gravity.
Now, there is an underlying notion
that one needs to understand in order to
even start talking about gravity
or in order to start talking about
matter and that is the notion of
space-time.
Now, space-time, of course, everybody
can have an intuitive notion. It's
somehow space and time together as one
big space, but that notion is not good
enough to talk precisely about it.
Now, a notion that is good enough is the
one I wrote down here. So, this is the
physical key definition, it's the
physical key object we need to talk
about and it underlies all modern
physics, all gravity all relativistic
physics and it is the following.
Space-time
this key notion is, I read it out
a four-dimensional
manifold
well, a topological manifold
that carries a smooth atlas, whatever
that is that carries a torsion-free,
whatever that is, connection, whatever
that is, compatible with a Lorentzian
metric. Maybe you have a rough idea.
And a time orientation, sounds clear
enough. Well, it has a precise
mathematical formulation that satisfies
the Einstein equations.
What does this mean?
Well, that's the purpose of these
lectures to clarify this definition. And
so, you see all the colored terms here
are terms we're going to define
precisely and the white words are just a
manner of speaking. Okay?
Um
and down here I wrote down the 24
lectures of the central lecture course
up to number 12 is half the month and
then the full school starts with
external lecturers, even more people, 50
scholarship holders from all over the
world, I think 23 countries and so on
come and that's the rest of the school.
And uh
those of you who are so lucky to be here
today don't have to follow this first
course online, but the others will. But,
you see this color code here, all these
unknown words um number one and two,
topological will be clarified in the
first lecture this morning, what uh
manifold is and it carries dimension
will be clarified in the second lecture
and all the other terms will be
clarified in the other color-coded
lectures and of course, in the remaining
lectures much more is going to be said
about how this game here works with the
Einstein equations, but first we need to
understand the central notion of
space-time.
So, that's our plan and
so, we have a tight schedule. Don't
hesitate to interrupt, just ask into the
classroom and I will give you very brief
answers. But, there will be a tutorial
this afternoon, actually every afternoon
after the lectures there's a tutorial.
There will be tutorial sheets out there.
They're very nice tutorial sheets, okay?
So, the new thing is you don't have to
think about them beforehand. You just go
there, you can have a look at the sheets
if you wish before you should pick up uh
one from each uh
uh stack
and but then actually we brought three
supervisors who'll take you through the
sheet and they're very simple exercises
that make you accustomed with all the
underlying notions. Okay? So, you'll
make much more of the school if you go
to these tutorials.
Okay, lecture one.
You invited us to
ask interrupt. Let me simply start this
tradition. Yes? All modern physics is a
rather broad claim. Yes, of course. I
mean, this is whenever I speak about
physics, I need to be a bit grand. So,
all modern fundamental relativistic
physics, I think that's true.
Okay, thank you very much.
So, lecture one is topological spaces.
So, we wish to talk about space-time and
at the coarsest level
so, if we don't look very closely, at
the coarsest level, space-time is a set.
Which means it just consists of points,
which you may call the elements of the
set and that is it.
However, this coarsest level is not
enough
to talk even about the simplest notions
we would like to talk about in classical
physics, namely continuity. Not enough
to talk
about
continuity
of maps.
So, you say, why do you do we want as
physicists to talk about continuity of
maps? Well, in classical physics, which
is this all about in classical physics
we have this idea that curves do not
jump.
No jumps.
So, if you have a curve, some particle
running somewhere, later on this will be
in space-time, we do not have the
situation that all of a sudden there is
a jump and say the trajectory of a
particle continues all of a sudden in a
totally different place. We do not want
that, so we need to require, for
instance, continuity of curves.
Now, a set is not enough structure to be
able to talk about curves being
continuous or not on that set.
And now, you could of course imagine all
kinds of structure on a set that allows
you to talk about continuity. For
instance, you could talk about a
distance measure or something.
But, we need to be very minimal and very
economic in order not to introduce undue
assumptions and so, we're interested in
the weakest structure we can establish
on a set
weakest structure
that can be
established
so, we need to do this by hand on a set
which allows
a good definition
of continuity of maps.
A set is not enough.
And mathematician know the weakest such
structure we can establish is a
so-called topology.
This is the reason for the physicist,
for the classical physicist to look at
topologies.
So, this is the motivation, this is the
little cloud, so if you wish uh
all of this
you as a mathematician
all of this you are allowed to think
you're thinking this, okay? This is your
motivation, but now we are precise.
Definition.
Um
let M be a set.
A topology
a topology, curly O
the O will be clarified later, it stands
for open. A topology with the name O is
a subset of what? Of the set M? No.
O is a subset of this monster P of M and
this monster P of M is a very simple
thing. It's called the so-called power
set.
It's the power
set
of M
is the set
containing all subsets
of M.
So, you make a choice
of certain subsets
of M. So, O is a set of sets.
A topology is a subset satisfying, not
any such subset, satisfying three
axioms.
And this you always need to check.
The first axiom is very simple.
You require that the empty set
which is certainly a subset of M,
the empty set
you require must always be part of your
collection that you call a topology. If
the empty set is not in there, the O
does not qualify as a so-called topology
for M.
There's another set that always must be
chosen to belong, namely M is clearly a
subset of M,
improper subset, it also needs to be in
the topology.
First axiom, very simple.
Second axiom, oh, well, they're all very
simple.
Uh the second axiom is the following.
Assume you have a set U that is in the
topology. So, you made a collection of
subsets
and say you've chosen one that's called
U.
And assume you have chosen a second one
that lies in there, that's called V.
Then, for any such U in V, it must be
true already. You need to check whether
their intersection
also has been chosen to belong to the
topology.
If that is not the case, the O already
disqualified
as a topology for the set M. It's very
abstract at the moment, but it's also
very simple. So, the more abstract, the
simpler it gets. We'll have many
examples. Okay?
The third axiom is
looks deceptively similar to this one,
but with not with an intersection, but
with a union.
But I say deceptively similar because
it's somewhat different. It says assume
you have sets U alpha
that are in O,
but not just U1 and U2, which I call U
and V, but this alpha can come from an
arbitrary index set. So, here, if you
wish, I chose index set one and two. I
have two sets.
But this index set could be the real
line. It could be more than countably
many
elements.
So, this can be a huge collection of
elements in this O. However, whatever
amount of sub- sets in O you look at,
the union, the big union over all of the
ones you already have in O, this big
union, these brackets are not necessary,
they make the thing clearer, this big
union also needs to be in O.
If that is not the case, then the whole
thing is not called a topology.
That's it.
This is the
key definition of topology.
And of course, the question is, what is
this all about? And the other question
is, can we have an example?
Examples. Let's start very simply.
Let's take a set M
that just consists of elements 1 2 3. We
need to understand this if we want to
understand anything.
Now, we could, for instance, make a
choice of subsets.
So, I make big brackets.
Okay?
Big brackets. And this O contains
subsets of M. For instance, it could
contain the empty set.
And it could contain the set 1 2 3
itself. And these are the only subsets
of M this O, let's call it O1,
contains.
The question is, is this a topology?
Yes, it is.
is
a topology. Let's quickly go through it.
The empty set lies in it. The entire
set, which is 1 2 3, lies in it.
We take two arbitrary sets and check
whether the intersection lies in there.
I choose this one as U, and I choose the
same one as V. Why not?
Empty intersected empty is empty. Empty
is already in there.
I take this one, empty intersected with
this one, empty intersected with
anything is empty. Empty is already in
there.
I take this one with that one. Well, the
intersection is symmetric. It's again
empty. Empty is already in there. I take
this one intersected with itself. It's 1
2 3 again. It's already in there.
Second axiom satisfied. Third axiom for
the unions, the same holds true. Here,
only finite unions. This is a topology,
please.
Topology have to be countable?
Um
No, in fact, it won't because, for
instance, if M is the integers, N,
then the power set of M is isomorphic to
the reals.
So, and the topology you can choose O as
the entire power set. That will be the
next example. So, the answer to your
question, does the topology have to be
countable? The answer is no, even if M
is countable.
Okay.
Um
Next example B,
same set up here, so the A should go
here.
O2 defined as the empty set,
the set one, the set two, and the set 1
2 3.
Is this a topology?
The answer is no because 1 union 2,
third axiom we need to check, 1 union 2
is the set 1 2, is not in there, is not
a topology.
Okay?
Now, um
you see, this is a very simple game if
you are able to write down the topology
explicitly.
Now,
there are two topologies you can
establish on any set.
So, let's do um example one, example
two.
M be any set.
So, for instance, the set of the
integers, all the integers, all the real
numbers, whatnot.
We have the following example. You can
choose the topology to be
to consist of only the empty set and the
entire set.
And this is a topology that has a
specific name. It's called the chaotic
topology. You can check this is a
topology for any set M.
There's a second topology
that you can always write down, and
that's the topology where you just take
any subset of the chosen set, just any
one. And because the intersection of two
subsets is always a subset, and the
union of two subsets is always a subset,
and all the subsets are in there, this
also is a topology. And this is called
the discrete topology.
Why should we worry about the chaotic
and the discrete topology? The answer is
because they're both utterly useless.
They're utterly useless, but they're
extreme cases. They're extreme cases
because this is the topology with the
fewest elements possible, and this is
the topology with the maximum amount of
elements possible. And they serve as
test cases in order to construct extreme
examples in topology in order to have an
understanding of what the notions depend
on. Sorry, my modification to O1 B
would be 1 B.
Uh it's not a topology because
It's not a topology since the union of 1
and 2 is the element is the set 1 2.
And that's 1 2 3.
And the set 1 2 is not an element of the
set because this is an element of the
set, this is an element, this is an
element, and this is an element.
Okay?
So, the union of M, but not the union of
Yes. Yes.
Exactly.
Okay. So, they're utterly useless, but
they serve as good examples.
Now, there is a very important example
that we're going to use throughout and
that will reconcile your intuition that
you of course have from undergraduate
analysis
of continuity, which we're going to
define soon, with the notion of
topology. And that is the so-called
standard topology. But whereas the
chaotic and discrete topology, these two
utterly useless ones, can be defined on
any set, the ones I'm going to define
now can only be defined on RD.
What is RD?
RD is R cross R cross dot dot dot cross
R. And what is that? That's the set of
all the
D tuples
of real numbers. So, the PI
are in the real numbers. So, in RD lie
tuples of D numbers.
Okay? That's RD, and that's a set.
And now, on this set, we want to
establish a topology.
We could establish the chaotic topology.
We could establish establish the
discrete topology. We could establish a
great number of different topologies.
We are now going to establish the
topology that is usually chosen
without saying it.
Okay?
That's the point. And this is called the
standard topology. So, we want to define
O standard. So, this needs to be a
subset of all the
subsets
of the power set of RD, of course,
because that's the topology. And you see
here, I explicitly wrote down all the
elements that belong to the topology.
The same here, I explicitly wrote it
down.
Now, the standard topology will contain
non-countably many
uh elements. I can impossibly write them
down explicitly. I have to define this
implicitly, and then to check whether
this nevertheless uniquely defines the
topology, okay? So, the way of
definition is somewhat different, but
the idea is of course the same.
And the definition proceeds in two
steps.
The first step is you define the
so-called soft balls.
What is a soft ball? A soft ball is a
set B uh sub R
of a point P. So, the point P is
supposed to be in RD,
and R is supposed to be an element of
the positive reals. Well, this is going
to be the radius of the ball, and this
is going to be the center of the ball,
if you like to think about it like this.
But in fact, it's just a set, namely
it's all the Q one
QD, that's a D-tuple, it's an element of
RD,
um for which it is true, and now it
comes, that if you take the Ith member
of this point in RD, you subtract from
it the Ith member of the central point.
So, if this is the point P in RD, then
it has components P1 to PD, okay?
You square the differences, you go from
I equals 1 to D, and you require that
the whole thing is less than R squared.
And of course, you see, oh, what you're
writing down here is just the Euclidean
norm, is what you say.
But I didn't speak of a norm, and I
don't need to speak of a norm. And this
is actually just defined on tuples. I do
not need a vector space structure on RD
to write this down.
To write down a norm, you do. Anyway,
this is the soft ball, and there's of
course a soft ball for any R and any P.
So, that's step number alpha. Now, step
number beta is the following.
We declare that a set U be
in the topology that we call the
standard topology
by definition
by definition if and only if, so that's
the definition, the implicit definition,
if the following is true.
If for every point P
of the set in question,
there exists
an R in R plus
such that
the soft ball BR of P lies entirely in
the set U.
This is the definition,
and of course,
you can just think of this in a very
simple way.
But this is thinking, and the other
thing is mathematics. You can think of
it in the following way. Assume you're
looking at R2, the special case, and you
think this is part of R2 in your
intuition.
And now I'll take this set here,
where the boundary does not belong to
the set,
roughly speaking.
And now the question is, is it true that
this set U
is it an element of the standard
topology? Well, yes, it is, because
whatever point in U you pick, you find a
intuition radius small enough such that
the soft ball whose
because there is not an equal sign,
right?
Whose soft ball lies entirely in there.
And that's true for every point.
Whereas, if you had taken only some part
of the boundary here to still belong to
the set, you could have chosen a point
on there,
right? For any point, it must be true.
But then, however small but positive you
choose the radius, you would always have
a problem here, because the ball
wouldn't lie fully in it.
So, this
new set U is not an element of the
topology, whereas before the set was.
And now it's a simple exercise, but for
reasons of time, I'm not going to give
it. It's a simple exercise you might
think about why it is true that the thus
implicitly defined topology satisfies
these three axioms.
Okay? Maybe you want to think about this
tonight.
Okay? It's a very simple It's a few-line
proof. Can I have the blackboard,
please? It's a few-lines proof, um
but but we'll leave it out.
But of course, these pictures you saw
before, and you would have probably said
this is an open set, and this is a a
non-open set, and so on. And this is
precisely the reason for defining this
special topology this way,
to do on RD what you always knew.
But it doesn't mean that there wouldn't
be opportunities
to maybe equip RD with a different
topology if you have other than the
standard purposes in mind.
And later on, what we are of course
going to do, we're going to think of M,
the set, as the points of space-time.
And one big question will be, what
topology should the physical space-time,
or rather our mathematical model it,
carry?
There is a huge choice of topologies.
Anything that fits into this scheme is a
topology. Anything that fits into this
scheme, as we will define now,
suffices to define continuity of maps.
Remember, we defined topologies in order
to be able to define continuity of maps.
Okay.
Um
So, this will be the next step, but
before I go there, please do not be
deterred if this is
abstract at first sight. I don't know
about your background. If you're a
mathematician, you'll say, well, this is
just how things go. If you're a
physicist, you sometimes have to
um
to think about
in what places you usually implicitly
make these assumptions. And one of the
tasks in order to understand space-time
is to make the implicit assumptions
explicit.
In fact, when Einstein wrote down
general relativity, uh he didn't
understand many of the implicit
assumptions, and it took him many, many
years to overcome
intuitive notions,
some might say obvious notions, that
nevertheless do not apply.
So, making things explicit uh allows you
to really understand the concepts. And
you need to trust me that none of the
mathematical notions I introduce
is
not necessary in order to understand the
physics. So, really, every single bit
later on, when we proceed it further in
the course, I will be able to point at
the notions and say, this is the
physical effect of this and that choice.
Okay? And it was actually, I think, in
the second half of the 20th century that
uh Wald and Ehlers, and so on, they
recognized general relativity, the
theory of space-time, gravity, and
matter, must be studied on the
differential geometry side at the level
of rigor that mathematicians study
differential geometry in order to really
come to terms with the subtle notions of
physics there.
Okay? So, you need to trust us that this
is the cleanest way to introduce it, and
everything is self-contained.
Okay, so this is my uh
these are my words of motivation here.
So, uh now we define the topology. We
see We saw a topology is something you
need to choose. It's not automatically
there. It's a choice. Whenever you make
a choice, it's giving It's providing
structure. So, we have the following
important terminology.
And this is now only terminology. It's
not definition.
Terminology.
So, we talked about M
being a set. In fact, you can make it a
problem, what on earth do we mean by a
set? A collection of elements? Great.
But what's an element, and what's a
collection? It's not so simple. You need
to actually write down axioms for for
set theory. We're not going to do this.
I leave you with the intuitive notion.
Uh
if in doubt, we do Zermelo-Fraenkel set
theory with the axiom of choice.
Don't worry.
Um
O, we call this a topology, and this is
a set of subsets of M with certain
properties.
Now, if you think of a set together with
a choice of topology, you think of this
pair.
I think them together and then this pair
is called a topological
space.
It's more than a set. It's a set with
additional with additional information.
Okay, that's a topological space. Now,
uh
if U is an element of O, if U is a
subset of M that lies in some chosen
topology, which I called O,
uh then we call U
an open set.
This is just topology uh that
terminology topology tool. Uh it's
a subset of M that happens to lie in the
chosen topology is called an open set.
So, the topology is the set of open
sets.
But, it's not like you would know what
open is and then you have the topology.
It's rather that open is defined by
having chosen a topology.
Okay?
That's an open set.
Then there is another
type of set. Let's call them A. Well,
it's just a set. Call a set A, which is
a subset of M, which is a subset of M.
Call the set A closed. Call it a closed
set.
When do we call it a closed set?
We call it a closed set by definition if
the complement
of A. So, if you take out A from the
total space, if the complement lies in
the topology.
And uh at this point you think, "Ah,
yeah, closed is the opposite of open in
some way." No, not in any way. There
open sets that are closed at the same
time. For instance, the empty set.
Because the empty set is in O,
but M without the empty set is all of M
is also in O. Ah, so the empty set is
also closed. So, the empty set is open
and closed at the same time, for
instance. There are sets that are
open, but not closed. There sets that
are not open, but closed. And there sets
that are not open and not closed.
Or in plain English, these two notions
in principle a priori have nothing to do
with each other whatsoever.
Of course, if you have chosen a
topology, they're connected by this
definition.
Okay? So, uh
I put up a warning sign. I will do this
several times during these lectures. And
the warning sign is that from open it
just generally not follow that a set is
closed, neither the other way around.
Despite the deceptive terminology.
Depends on what you look at. For
instance, if you're a vacuum physicist,
in many cases you indeed find examples
where this where this is useful.
Okay.
And nevertheless, it belongs to the
whole picture. You cannot understand the
other bits if you don't understand the
extreme cases. That's the point.
Okay.
So,
now we got ourselves a topology. We got
ourselves a number of notions you
usually talk about.
But now, why did we afford to buy a
topology in our favorite topology shop?
Okay? The point is it does us a service.
It yields a notion of continuous maps.
Second, continuous
maps.
Okay.
Now,
first of all, we need to talk about a
map.
And you all know what a map is. A map is
something that we call F, for instance.
And it goes from one set into another
set. So, M is a set, N is a set. And
this set we of course call the domain.
And this set
we call the target set.
And a map is of course nothing but if I
picture the set M by the collection of
its elements,
and I picture the set N by the
collection of its elements,
then a map, you know it, takes every
point from the domain
to some point over there. For instance,
these two points
can be taken to the same point, not a
problem.
Um
So, it's all the map F.
This point can be taken here.
That point can be taken there.
And but there is no need that every
point is hit. For instance, this point
is not hit.
Okay?
And this point here
is being hit twice.
We have notions for that. If such
diamond points exist, uh we say the map
F
the map F
uh is not surjective.
Because they're certain not surjective
because certain points in the target are
not hit.
If there exist points like the flower
point,
then we say the map is not
injective.
Because some points in the target set
are hit more than once. You know these
notions, injective maps, surjective
maps, and maps.
And a map is only defined between two
sets.
You need no further structure on the set
in order to say what a map is, right?
And not in order to say what in the set
injective or surjective is.
If it is injective and surjective, it's
called of course called bijective and so
on.
However,
I give you this map and I ask you a
simple question, is this map continuous?
Does it make jumps?
Now, you may have an intuition of
whether it does or not. And the answer
is it depends. On what does it depend on
whether this map is continuous? Well, in
fact,
so the the answer
to the question
of whether
a map
F from M to N
is continuous
depends,
and it does so by definition, so not by
some
uh divine intervention, but because
we're going to define continuity like
this, depends by definition
on
what topologies are chosen,
what topologies
I think better English is which
topologies are chosen
on the domain M and
the target space N.
So, in order to decide continuity of a
map, you need to decide on some topology
here, and you say that's the one I want
here, and on a topology there, and only
then can we write down a meaningful,
useful definition of continuity.
So, this is again all
the motivation around it. Let me be
precise.
Let M
be a topological space with a topology,
which gets the name OM. So, remember
it's the topology we established or we
chose on M.
And let
the set N be equipped with a, of course,
maybe totally different topology,
because if this is a different set than
this one, it can never be the same
topology, right?
Let these two be topological spaces.
So, they're sets on which which you each
of which you gave more structure.
Then
a map
F
that takes you from one set into the
other, and maybe for future reference,
you know, this is this is the name of
the map. This is the set it starts from.
This is the set it goes to. For future
reference, I also say if you now pick a
specific element in M, then this is
being mapped to. So, this arrow is a
little bit like these arrows here.
Okay?
Um this takes the individual element to
what we call
the image of this value in M, and this
lies of course in N.
And if these are, say, real numbers,
then maybe you can give a definite
prescription. This is M squared or
something like this. F of M is M squared
or something. So, this is the notation
we're going to use. This is the domain.
This is the target. And this is an
explicit description of how it's being
mapped. And if depending on what the
sets are, uh
you need to prescribe how this goes. In
the worst case, you have to draw a
picture.
Okay? Whatever it takes, you do this.
Okay. So, but this is actually true
however it is described. We always
assume, if I say a map, I assume there
is some definite prescription given.
Okay?
Some definite prescription is given,
then a map F from M to N
is called
continuous.
And continuous is such a word, in fact,
the full family name of continuous is
continuous with respect to the topology
OM on N and with respect to the topology
ON on N.
But we don't always say that, we just
say it is continuous, but now you're
educated, you know, ah, specific
topologies have been chosen and it's
with respect to those is called
continuous with respect to OM and ON if
and this must be the simplest definition
ever,
if
for every
set
that is open in the target. So, you take
any open subset here in the target
space, you must check for everyone if
for every V open in here
the so-called pre-image,
the grand name, it's a very simple
concept, the so-called pre-image of F
with respect to F
of this chosen set
is in fact an open set
in the domain.
Okay? Of course, what you need to
remember
is the definition of pre-image.
So, you have a map from M to N. Now, we
take a subset V in N. It may be open and
in fact, the definition of continuity
requires you take an open subset
but the definition of pre-image doesn't
care whether it's open or not.
Could be any.
Then the pre-image
of this chosen subset in the domain, in
the target with respect to the map F is
what? It's a subset of the domain.
Hence, we can ask is it open in the
domain?
Which subset in the domain? It's so
simple. It's all those elements in the
domain
which, if we map them using our F
come to lie
in this V.
This is very simple. Look at this Look
at this image again.
What is the another color.
What if I choose these two here
as the subset V in the target, these two
elements as the subset V in the target,
what's the pre-image of this subset with
respect to F? Well, you follow the
arrows backwards. This one lies in the
pre-image and this one lies in the
pre-image. This one doesn't because it
doesn't come to lie in V. So, these two
are the pre-image
with respect to F of the chosen set V.
So, you say, well, it's kind of the
inverse.
Yeah, careful
because look at the flower set.
I could take another set V twiddle
and with only this element, the flower
point.
What's the pre-image of the V twiddle
set with respect to F? Well, you follow
all the arrows backwards.
It's this set. This is the pre-image
of V twiddle with respect to F because
each of those F of each of those comes
to lie in V.
And now you see, ah, even if the map is
not invertible or where the map is not
invertible, the pre-image has a notion,
but the pre-image of the single one
would be the single one, the pre-image
of the single one would be this single
one. That's of course a sign of an
invertible part of a map, but here it
isn't, but still the pre-image is the
whole subset in the domain.
So, you check is every open set here,
that depends on the chosen topology, is
the pre-image of every open set open in
here? Depends on that topology. It's a
very simple concept and it's extremely
powerful. And that's it, that's
continuity. No epsilons, no deltas,
very simple, very simple.
Yes? If
the image is, say, the
crowded guy?
Uh, the the the diamond guy? So, the
diamond guy? So, you say if V is the
diamond guy, well, that's very simple.
What is it? What's the pre-image?
Empty Pre-image empty set, very good.
So, the pre-image of V twiddle twiddle,
so that's the
the set with only the diamond element,
uh, this is the empty set.
And the empty set is open. So, if this
one happened to be an open set or
constitute an open set all by itself, at
least under this map, this wouldn't
destroy continuity. This one wouldn't.
Okay?
Very well. And therefore, you see how
important it is to have uh, the empty
set in the topology because otherwise,
if you make this definition, only
surjective maps could be continuous,
which is of course nonsense. Yes? In
this picture, where do you see the
topology?
The topology.
Here you don't. That's the point. So, as
I said, um, the pre-image is defined at
the map level. The map level only
defines to the set structure level. This
can all be written and of course, if I
want to define continuity in terms of
topologies, I can only put conditions
here. This is defined on the set level,
but then here you chose one in the
topology in the target and you check
whether it's in topology in the domain.
For this definition, you need the
topologies. For the definition of the
pre-images, you don't. And in fact, I
cannot I still cannot say, even if I
understand all the pre-images of all the
subsets, I still cannot say whether this
specific map is continuous unless I
decided for a certain topology here and
there.
And that's given here. So, let's let's
make an example. Yes?
For example, can I have a map that makes
a jump in the topology in the topology?
So, if I have a set M and N, topology
one and topology one and two, can I have
a map that makes a connection between
those two? If I choose Yes, in fact, the
continuous maps
as it says, it's I mean, if the map was,
let's say the map was bijective, it was
a one-to-one map
then the pre-image could of course be
written as F inverse of the set V, of
the set V.
And then, if you have maps that are
continuous in both directions, then not
only the pre-images of open sets are
open, but also the images of open sets
are open because the inverse pulls it
back, the image the pre-image of the
inverse is the image of the map.
And so, it's maps that are bijective and
in both directions continuous, they
preserve the topological structure and
they have a specific name, they're
called homeomorphisms.
In German, homeo-morphisms,
in English, homeo-e-o,
homeomorphisms and they are the
structure-preserving maps of topology.
That's exactly it. It's a very, very
deep question because mathematicians
always classify structures by
identifying them if certain
structure-preserving maps between them
exist.
Okay, fine. So, let's
further question at this point?
Good. So,
let's make an
example. No, I already had an example.
Yes, but I would like to write down the
mnemonic
phrase. So, if you want to remember this
definition, it's very easy to remember
a map
is continuous
if and only if, well, it's the if of a
definition, so exactly if, is continuous
if
the pre-images
of, in brackets, all of course we mean
open sets
are open sets.
The pre-images of open sets are open
sets. The only point is that the
pre-image of open sets, and here you
should say
in the target space are open sets
in the domain because the pre-image lies
in the domain and the pre-image of a map
uh, of a
of a subset needs to be the subset a
subset in the target because otherwise,
you can't take the pre-image.
So, the short formula, pre-images of
open sets are open sets. These open sets
refer to a topology on the target,
whereas these, of course, must refer to
a to to a topology on the domain as it's
written down precisely here.
Okay? So, that is
Yes. Yes. Um, was one of the uh
uh
Do we use uh, topology from now on with
the standard No. No, and I can't because
I I I emphasize that the standard
topology is only defined on R to the D.
This here is not an R to the D.
So, on this one, I can't define the
standard topology.
It's a very important thing. So, and the
standard topology, it has this deceptive
name standard topology as if there was
anything mathematically special about
it. There's nothing special about the
standard topology other than that you
like it because it was the first
topology you implicitly met in the
beginning of your studies.
Okay, but that's not a good reason for
space-time to carry it.
Right? So this is a very important
point. It's called standard and that
reconcile makes you I mean this is
somehow to to make you happy
and other people do the same trick. Um
but it means nothing and and it can only
be established on some RD where it's on
an arbitrary set it can't even be talked
about.
Okay?
Very important point. So we take it
always very general unless we say which
one which one we chose.
Okay.
So um
Aha.
Okay, let's let's make an example. Let's
make an example and in fact I had one. I
don't find it so I
Ah.
Haha, here it is.
Example. So let's say M is the set 1 2
3. We had it before.
And let's say N the target is the same
set. Why not? I can go from set 1 to 3
to the set 1 2 3 uh with a map. No, we
make it even simpler. We only take 1 and
2 and 1 and 2.
So let's invent a map. One map is
there's the one, there's the two,
there's the set 1 2 again and just for
fun I set I map the one to the two and I
map the two
to the one. Why would I not do that? Uh
that's the map F from M to N
I want to look at. Okay? Very simple
one.
And now I establish topologies
on these sets
and I choose Well, it's a definition. I
choose to establish on M the topology
with the elements empty set uh set with
element one, set with element two
and set
1 2. This is a topology.
And on N I establish a different
topology. Although it's the same set,
I'm free to choose a different topology.
I establish the empty set 1 2. That's a
topology, too.
So the question is is F continuous?
What do we have to
to check
whether
F continuous?
Again, not by all by itself but with
respect to the chosen topologies,
whether F is continuous, we need to
check what is the pre-image with respect
to F of just every open subset
This is this all for all for just every
open subset
in the target, we need to check whether
the pre-image
lies is an open subset
in the domain.
What are the open subsets of the target?
Well, I can completely enumerate that. I
need to study these two pre-images
because these are the only open sets in
the target.
What is the pre-image of the empty set?
What are all the elements in here that
come to lie nowhere?
None.
Because it's a map.
Everything is mapped
by the definition of map.
What is the pre-image of the set 1 2
with respect to F? Well, set 1 2 is the
entire set. The pre-image is the entire
set. So this is all of M. Correct?
But all of M by the axioms of a topology
lies in OM and the empty set also lies
in OM.
So in fact we checked thus
F is continuous.
This map is continuous.
Now you will be very surprised
because this was only part A of it.
Now I do part B
and I do the following thing. I now look
at the map that goes the opposite way
that starts in here and goes in here
which as a set is the same thing so I
call this the map G because it has a
different domain, different target.
And again N is 1 2, M is 1 2 and the G
map be defined by this. You say it's the
same map. Has exactly the same
prescription. Yes?
The explanation that you gave
for
pre-image of the empty set
is in the topology on M
that this is due to the
the fact that M is a map?
Okay. So
we're talking about this equal sign is
in question or
No, it's
the argument that you gave verbally.
But okay. So the point is the pre-image
of the empty set with respect to F is
let's see whether I was right is the set
of all M in M for which F of M lies in
the empty set.
Now, if F is a map
then every element of M is mapped to
some element of the target.
Uh so it's an element of the target but
not of the empty set because if F of M
was in the empty set then this M
wouldn't have an image.
But because F is a map, every element
here must have an image. If the map
would the notion of a map would allow
for this little Christmas tree point
here
to not be mapped. If this was still a
map, if only these guys are mapped but
this one isn't, then the image of this
under F would be nothing because there
is no image.
Yes, but then M would not still not be
in the pre-image. I'm I'm saying this is
the argument to show the second. Okay,
no M in M satisfies this. So you take
all the M in M that satisfy this
condition.
But any M in M is mapped to a non-empty
to something in N. Hence none of these
satisfies this condition. So none
no condition I so that means it's the
empty set.
I think it's clear. It's Ultimately it's
the definition of map.
Maybe we can discuss later if you if
you're not satisfied. I think that's
true. Okay. So now we go the opposite
direction. I again give this
prescription. You say, "Oh, it's the map
F."
Because well, M actually is N and
Okay, you're right. It's actually the
map F.
But not if I keep with it that the M is
equipped with one topology and the N is
equipped with another topology because I
now have this other topology on the
domain and the other topology on the
target.
I could have also said I swapped the
topologies. But uh you can also think of
this G as the inverse of F, the inverse
map because that is what it is, right?
Exchanges 1 2 and it exchanges it back.
You say, "Well, if the map is
continuous, the bijective map, the
inverse will be continuous, too."
Well,
check for every open set in here, for
every open set in here, check whether
the pre-image is open.
So we start pre-image with respect to F
inverse
of
um
of one.
So I take an open set in the target.
Let's start with this one. Of course I
start with this one because this already
spells catastrophe so I don't need to
write too much. So if it's true and I
must check for every open set in here,
so for instance for this one, what's the
pre-image of the set with the element
one? Well, it's the set with the element
two, right?
But the set with the element two,
unfortunately, cannot be found anywhere
in the topology of the now domain.
Not continuous.
F inverse
not
continuous.
And to make it even worse, if I hadn't
exchanged 1 and 2, it would be the
identity map
from one space with one topology to
another space to the same space with
another topology. The identity map could
be continuous in one direction and the
inverse of the identity map, which is of
course the identity map again
could be not continuous
because you chose different topologies.
Do you see how dangerous it is to not
explicitly talk about the topologies?
Uh blackboard, please. Uh
Can you
refresh my memory?
I I of course I do remember
uh when an open set
the picture you
you draw that the boundary uh what is
the difference between an open and a
closed set in the example? In these
examples. Okay. So let's for instance um
focus on this topology. Okay? And let me
write down an
um
a closed set for you.
I claim that two
which is an open set
I claim that it's also closed.
I claim two is closed since What do I
need to check? I need to check whether
the entire set without that set
is in the topology, but it is because
the entire set is one two. One two
without two is one.
But one we see also lies in there.
For instance, okay? It has nothing to do
whatsoever with the image of the
boundary being there or not. Although
boundary, this notion we have in the
standard topology, can be defined for
any topology. So these notions carry
over, but our pictures of the notions
not necessarily do.
That that would be an example. So this
has nothing to do with continuity, but
is a remark on the previous terminology
on closed sets.
Okay.
So we introduced our little notion of
continuity
for general maps between any two
topological spaces. Now in the beginning
I drew this curve
in a set that makes a jump all of a
sudden.
What does it mean? Is it not continuous?
Well, a curve would be something that
goes from the real line, which is the
curve parameter, if you wish, into some
other set.
But you need to equip the real line, the
parameter space where the curve takes it
param its parameters, with a topology,
and you need to equip the space in which
the curve runs
also with a topology in order to start
talking about the curve making jumps or
not. Where making jumps I translate as
is continuous or not.
And
in the few in the following in the whole
lectures, whenever we have the real
numbers or the real numbers cross the
real numbers cross to R to the D,
if nothing else is said, I will always
implicitly assume that we establish the
standard topology. The standard topology
on the line, the real line, and the
standard topology on the real plane. So
if nothing is said, then R or RD carries
the standard topology, so I don't need
to write so much.
Okay?
But the other spaces we will have in
spacetime will not be RD
or R4 or something. Spacetime will be a
topological space all in by itself.
Okay. Anyway, so that was this remark.
Now,
uh there is a very important
notion of composition of maps, which is
again defined at the set level and the
map and set level, but you can ask, what
is is the composition of two continuous
maps, is it again continuous? And that's
a very important question. So that's
section number
three, composition.
Composition
of continuous maps.
So the situation is very simple. You
have a map F that goes from M to N, and
sometimes I write the F on the arrow.
That means the same as before. It takes
you from the domain to the target. And
imagine there is another
uh map G that takes you from the target
to yet another target.
And then you can define a new map from
the data given these two F and G, you
may define a map that's called G after F
or first F then G, so G after F,
which is a map
as it's indicated here from M to P.
And now I can tell you how the
composition is made. An element in M is
being mapped to Well, that's the name of
the game, G after F of M. But this now
has a definition, and the definition is
you first apply F, and then you apply G.
Of course, the composition of maps uh
if you can write it down so simply, why
do you introduce this notation? Well,
this is the map,
and this is already the image of of a
point under the map.
So I want to like to be able to talk
about the map itself. That's why I call
this G after F. And we have a key
theorem, very simple to prove.
Maybe we'll do this. Key theorem. It
says if F is continuous
and G is continuous,
then it follows that G after F is also
continuous.
Let's prove this.
Just for fun.
What do we need to check? We need to
check whether G after F is continuous,
and we may assume this. So G after F
continuous, we need to check
let V be any open set in the topology on
P. I have of course chosen topologies
OM, ON, OP.
If V is any open set in here, I study
the pre-image
of G after F of this subset. What is the
pre-image? Well, by definition, it's all
those M in the domain of the map such
that G after F of the M comes to lie in
the chosen open set.
But what is this? This is all the M in M
for which F of M lies in the pre-image
of G with respect to G
of this V.
Okay?
But that is of course nothing but the
pre-image with respect to F of the
pre-image with respect to G of V.
Ah, but G is continuous, and V is an
open set in the target of G as well. So
this must be an element by this
continuity must be an element in ON.
Ah, but F is continuous, so and this is
an open set here in the target, so it
must be an open set
in the domain of F.
Ah, but this is what we wanted to show.
For any open set here, the pre-image
with respect to this map is open here,
which we just did. So the theorem is
proven.
Do this with epsilons and deltas in RD.
Okay?
But this is always true.
We only use the definition of continuity
and the topological space.
Okay?
Very important thing.
Last thing for today, 6 minutes.
Inheriting
a topology.
If you're old enough, you know that
inheritance is a good thing.
And um
it's also good if you have some
topological space, you have a topology
somewhere, or you have one or two or
three topological spaces, construct a
new one from what you already got.
And one There are many ways to inherit
topologies from sets, and every way to
inherit a topology in a certain
situation has a certain advantage. One
we need is I should say many useful
ways.
Many useful
ways
to
uh inherit
a topology
from
some given
topological
space, or depending on the construction
spaces, maybe you have three parents.
Um
Important for us, particularly important
for us,
for spacetime physics, so that the
physicists keep motivated, uh spacetime
physics,
is the following. Assume you have a set
M
on which
you are happy enough to already be given
a topology. You already have a
topological space.
And now you consider a subset S
of a topological space.
Some sub Not an open subset, any subset.
Could be any subset.
Question, can you make S itself into a
topology?
Question.
Can one construct
on S
or for S a topology
from
the topology OM on M?
Of course, I mean, I can always invent a
topology on S,
but maybe I want a special topology that
in some way I get from M, and I'll tell
you in a second why this is interesting.
And the answer is yes.
And an important way to do so is the
so-called subset topology. You define a
topology on S. This now not OS, but O /
S, so the restriction to S, if you want.
But this now needs to be a subset of the
power set of S.
Supposed to be a topology on S.
Define this OS as follows explicitly.
You say it's all the sets that have the
shape U intersected S. So any element in
the topology must be writable as U
intersection S,
where U is any set in the given topology
you already have.
That's the definition, and there is a
claim. Well, you can call this a
topology, and it's actually called the
subset topology.
Subset topology in brackets inherited
from topology on the superset.
Well, M is the superset.
M is the superset of S.
But the claim is it really is a
topology. I don't only call it a
topology, it is a topology. Let's very
quickly check that. We need to check is
the empty set
as a subset of S, is it in there? Well,
of course it is because I can write the
empty set as the empty set as a subset
of M intersected S.
This is clearly true.
But because this here is in OM,
it follows that the empty set is in OS
as it is defined. What about the whole
set S? The whole set S needs to be in
the topology of S. I write the whole set
of S, I write it as M intersected S.
Well, M intersected S is clearly S
because S is a subset, but M is in OM,
so the set S is of the form some open
set in M intersected S. So, therefore,
the whole set S is in the topology.
Second axiom,
let's take a U
uh
a U in S and a V in S. Now, it's getting
confusing. Uh I should call this
uh yeah. A in S and B in S, I need to
check whether the intersection is in S.
Well, if A is in S, then it means there
exists an A twiddle in OM and a B
twiddle in OM such that A is A twiddle
intersected S and B is B twiddle
intersected S because I say all open
sets in S Oh, sorry. They should be in
OS.
Right? Uh must have this form. But if
this is true, I can study the
intersection A intersected B is A
twiddle intersected S brackets
intersected B twiddle intersected S
bracket. But of course, the bracket is
asso- the
intersection is associative, so and and
S intersected S is S and so on, so I get
A twiddle intersected B twiddle
intersected S. But A twiddle B twiddle
lie in OM, but that's a topology, so
they lie in here. So, again, the
intersection of A and B is of this form,
so the whole thing here lies in OS,
and for the union, it's the same thing.
Okay? I'm not going to write it down for
time reasons. So, in fact, we define
something, we call it a topology, but
then of course, we can prove it's a
topology.
Final word,
use
of this specific
way
to inherit
to inherit a topology
uh from a superset.
Well, the idea is the following.
Very often, it's very easy for you to
judge whether a certain map
from M to N where you know the topology
on here and you know the topology on
here is continuous. Let's assume because
of the specific topologies chosen, I'll
give you an exa- an example in a second.
Let's assume it's very easy to decide
whether this is continuous.
Continuous. Say that's easy. For some
reason, we know.
Now, you want to know something
different. You want to know if you only
consider a subset of the original domain
and you consider the map from the subset
into N, which you usually call the
restriction of F
only to the subset.
You want to do this very often. For
example, from R2 to R,
you write down some prescription how
this maps. Um then you know every point
of R2,
how it goes to the real line somehow.
For instance, a temperature distribution
where these are the isotherms, right?
It's a temperature distribution.
Such a map. Right?
Now, imagine for some reason, you're not
interested in the temperature on this
hot plate, but on this hot plate, you
have a little wire that goes like this.
And for some reason, you have a mouse
that you mounted onto the wire with some
little wheels. Okay?
And the mouse is only interested, so if
this is the subset S of R2, the mouse is
of course only interested in the
temperature where it can pass. It's a
very natural situation, and it's very
natural to decide the continuity of such
a map. You use your undergraduate
analysis notion.
But if this is a complicated wire, this
map here, T sub S, well, that's quite a
beast. It can look very complicated
because this here is given in a
complicated way. Now, assume this is
continuous with respect to the standard
topology on here and here.
Okay? Then, if you decide
to equip S
with just some topology you come up
with, then you cannot conclude that if
this is continuous, then this will be
continuous, too, because it depends on
the topology you choose on the subset S.
But if you decide to choose on S the
topology you have on here by inheriting
it to here, so constructing from this
topology this specific one I wrote down
here, then you're guaranteed, then it
follows that the restriction of the map,
which then goes from S to N, is again
continuous.
Okay? Then you see it's a very natural
thing to consider this particular one.
This can also be proven in a few lines.
Again, we're already 3 minutes over
time. I'm not going to do this. So, the
wrap-up is
we defined, we took a set, we
established the topology in order to
talk about continuity.
If you leave the room, uh I hope there
are the problem sheets.
Not yet? Okay, after the coffee break,
after the coffee break, there are two
tables and there are a number of problem
sheets on from each stack, you take a
sheet, and those are the problem sheets
for the first lecture this morning and
for the second lecture. In these problem
sheets, you just come to the tutorial
this afternoon. Where are they? In the
bank bank building, lower floor.
Okay? You come there, we divide you into
groups, you sit there, and you go
through a worksheet under the competent
advice of our tutors, and you practice
these notions. Please come. It will
really make everything very clear and
you're fully prepared for the next round
of lectures on Wednesday. So, we have
now half an hour coffee break. Is that
correct? And then at a quarter to, we
start again. Next lecture, topological
manifolds. Thank you.